villiger hat die hose bitte lasst bitte
bitte nicht wenigstens die uhr soll
[Musik]
engel war und jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video ich muss wirklich sagen ich
hatte schon lange nicht mehr so trocken
video zu drehen wir jetzt genau gerade
in diesem moment ist wegen bürger du
machst jetzt ein video und erzählt den
leuten etwas von einer wie ich gerade
wirklich feststellen musste sehr sehr
sehr dunklen schlimmen vergangenheit
bevor wir allerdings starten habe ich
mir gedacht ja komm setz doch mal wieder
eine treppe habe ich schon so lange
nicht mehr gemacht ich weiß nicht also
habe ich mir schon sehr viele leute
gesagt hey das steht eigentlich voll gut
zu dieser art von cap sie könnte aber in
die kommentare schreiben
ob ihr findet dass das scheiße aussieht
oder auf das scheiße aussieht passt
einfach mal eure medikation in den
kommentaren da und die werde ich mit
handtuch lesen und mich richtig geil
fühlen weil ihr bestimmt alle sagen
werdet ihr alex du bist der geilste
junge dieser welt das weiß ich
eigentlich aus und war natürlich nur ein
willst jetzt nehme ich weiß dass ich
packe bekommen wir fangen auf der einen
seite könnte ich natürlich jetzt einfach
loslaufen und euch ein bisschen was
erzähle ich habe mir allerdings so ein
paar fragen als stütze rausgesucht die
ich beantworten werde wo man dass wir
das intimste video alle okay leute habe
ich schon mal so viel getrunken lasse
ich den weg nach hause nicht mehr
gefunden hat ich muss auf der einen
seite erst mal sagen ich bin eigentlich
gar nicht mehr so der fan von alkohol so
ich habe auch vor darüber noch mal ein
video zu machen so der erste kontakt mit
alkohol und so weiß ich nicht ist voll
ich mein ding so mehr so klar man trinkt
ab und zu mal alkohol wenn man 16 ist
das voll normaal das macht jeder
jugendliche also fast jeder jugendliche
und das ist auch in der jugend komplett
normal dass man irgendwann mal so zu
viel davon konsumiert hatte ich meine
das kennen viele wahrscheinlich von euch
allerdings als gut weil wir bei den
orientierungssinn ist wirklich der
berner deswegen irgendwie war ich immer
zu hause denn ich erinnere mich daran
eine story aus clown da war es auf jeden
fall witzig du hast doch nie den namen
eines anderen während dem sex
ausgesprochen
nein habe ich nicht ich verstehe auch
gar nicht wie das funktionieren soll ich
mein vito bußmann habt ihr denn sein da
gehört schon eine menge intelligenz kurz
hier vorher was da gehört auf jeden fall
schon eine menge dummheit zu du hast
noch nie erotische fotos von dir
schießen lassen leute was da auf
folgendes problem bei mir wenn ich
schreiber gehe unterliegende da komme
man so viele leute an und fotografie und
die strecken so hey leute kommen nein
spaß aber jetzt bescheid ich muss doch
einfach nur ein foto von ihm machen und
das ist gleich tausend mal erotischer
als andere fotos von irgendwelchen
anderen personen oder nicht heute in
diesem video kann ich echt aber ganz
rüberkommen aber nein leute das ist
natürlich nur spaß
ich finde mich nicht geil obwohl ich in
einer recht jetzt reicht's aber jetzt
reicht's aber auf der anderen seite so
klar jeder schießt man von sich selber
vielleicht das ein oder andere erotische
fotos gucken sie das dann läuft es dann
wieder weiß doch nicht erotisch ist so
ist das bei mir zumindest kennt ihr das
ihr betracht euch so im spiegel so hasse
ich heute wieder gut aus dann macht ihr
ein foto das sind doch jetzt zwei
verschiedene welten ihr foto und spiegel
du hast noch nie jemand zufällig nackt
gesehen den du nicht hörte zufällig
nackt sehen sollen leute das ist mir in
meiner vergangenheit schon so oft
passiert so man geht so irgendwo weil
seine freunde da so ins bagno scheiße
nein kennt ihr das ihr kennt das
bestimmt oder du hast noch nie heimlich
deine nachbarin beobachtet also ich
persönlich finde ja so was geht gar
nicht jeder hat seine privatsphäre
verdient aber manche wollen ist halt
nicht nur wenig anders ich meine wenn
ich jetzt schon wieder zum fenster hier
passt mal auf bitte das jetzt mbh an
bitte billiger die hose böse anlass und
bitte beschluss wichtigstens die hosen
und einmal das kann doch nicht wahr sein
leute ich stehe einmal im fenster und es
passiert immer das gleiche bei der
hildegard kann man so perfekt rein
gucken
ein letzter kurzer rast kristen perry
knights englisch du musst es noch nie
von der polizei viele leute wir haben
wirklich vor zehn jahren oder fünf
jahren weiß ich nicht wie ein leichter
zwölf oder dreizehn ihr müsst euch das
so vorstellen ich habe auf der einen
seite freunde die sind relativ normal
also da war vor fünf jahren und dann hab
ich also die frau habe ich heute auch
noch aber wie war damals halt komplett
bescheuert wir haben also ein game
gezockt das hieß hecken job da haben wir
uns einfach irgendwo von der hecke
gestellt sind darüber gesprungen wie
auch immer und durch gegenwärtige
auch so richtig dumm einfach dumm und
jordan haben dann auch leute mal die
polizei gerufen und die haben uns dann
gesucht das war wirklich so also die
sind so sie haben uns nicht bekommen
aber das war schon relativ
offensichtlich dass sie uns gesucht
haben und ich glaube ich hat noch nie so
schlimm wie in diesem moment stellt euch
vor ihr werdet mit zwölf jahren einfach
von der polizei verfolgt was ist denn
das aber ist nicht mal was aus mir
geworden ist ein ganz vernünftiger
jugendlicher eigentlich ist doch ein
paar ausnahmen eher gut das war ein
kleiner teil war doch schon ziemlich
dunklen vergangenheit wir wahrscheinlich
gemerkt habt oder findet ihr jetzt noch
nicht also ich sind schon ziemlich hart
für kriminell wenn euch dieses video
gefeiert ihr vielleicht bekommt auch den
zweiten teil der last auf jeden fall
erstmal daumen nach oben da ich mit
sagen bei 15 sagen wir 12.000 gibt es im
zweiten teil hiervon ich bin sehr
gespannt würde mich auch freuen jürgen
link geht so weiter wenn man im letzten
video chat instagram als eingewandert
könnt ihr mir gerne folgen instagram
bietet super anpassen
da wird jetzt sogar durch gehört hast
was auch immer ist auch scheißegal
wir sehen uns am nächsten donnerstag
wieder ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
tag heute